our International Affairs editor Dominic
wankorn reports now from Alton Graber in
Eastern Germany and his report contained
some flash photography
showing off its armor
the day after a historic decision to
send other tanks to fight in Ukraine
Germans may be sensitive about the
military for obvious reasons but they
are moving on from that and taking on a
more assertive role what message do you
think sending the leopards to Ukraine
sends to Vladimir Putin that German
doesn't pretend doesn't remember that we
stand with Ukraine I did the hesitation
was that time lost do you think we're
negotiating
Germany's new defense minister was here
to watch Puma fighting vehicles in
action
it's the leopard 2 their Flagship tank
that's being sent to Ukraine after the
green light from Berlin
but only after agonizing soul-searching
in Germany about its military role
Boris Pastorius insists they will still
get there in time to stop any Russian
offensive
I don't have any hints that it could be
too late because I think we will deliver
our own airports the ladies maybe at the
end of March and as everything I love it
is early enough
officially this is Germany's defense
minister meeting his troops for the
first time in his new job but this is
clearly designed to send a wider message
to Germany's allies and to Moscow that
this country is now fully engaged and
prepared to send Ukraine what it needs
to fight this war
ehouse
in Moscow propagandists are Furious
comparing Germany's chancellor to Hitler
rights geeker
Nazis came Rush
predating
any counselor Germany
tellingly the Russians today release
footage of aircraft that can be used
against tanks Moscow says Western tanks
will be destroyed Western experts say
they will need more air cover
sending tanks will speed up Russia's
defeat hopes the west but war is
unpredictable and this conflict is
escalating again Dominic wirecorn Sky
News Alton grabo Eastern Germany